[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof
good day walter hi martin
we are back again yes we're back
it's becoming a habit like we said about
100 episodes ago
correct
and
this time's a little bit of a struggle
because
we i don't know what it is but
whatever it was it was worse than what
they called covert
the enemy has so many different
areas that he can hit yes
and i've just realized through this week
again
our dependence
is totally have to be on god absolutely
we're
we are certainly in a very very
interesting time
and
you know in the old days you'd get flu
and that would be okay but these things
they just don't let go
i don't know what it is what they've
done what toxin is involved let's not go
there let's just say
thank god god helps us to deal with it
amen let's pray
our heavenly father thank you for this
opportunity
of
discussing your word
and
looking forward to the day when you come
to fetch us
we've got a job to do and that's why we
ask you to help us with
with it
enlightening our minds with the holy
spirit and guiding our speech in jesus
name amen amen
now
we have had so many requests to please
do a question and answer again right
and so
we decided okay let's let's do one there
are still many many questions
we tried to answer many of them
on the internet
but
some just keep on coming back coming
back so
yeah let's let's delve into it yes okay
well one of the first questions
that i keep forgetting and asking you is
a lot of people want to know
what this is
this
what that picture is yes and why it's
important
well it's a very special picture let me
put it that way because
in 2017
that was the year of
the commemoration of the reformation yes
october 31st
500 years of reformation that's the
first time that the protestant world
and
the catholic world celebrated it
basically together
so they were basically
celebrating
the healing of a wound
now i don't know whether
prophetically that should be something
to be celebrated it is a tragedy as far
as i am concerned because you cannot
compromise
when it comes to
christ and his mission and the plan of
salvation that's true
and you cannot compromise when it comes
to the word or tradition because to the
lord to the testimony if they speak not
according to this word there is no light
in them on that occasion we had
opportunity to visit many protestant
sites
and to do a number of recordings and one
of the sites we visited was the
gutenberg
museum
that's where you have the gutenberg
press right
and
that's probably one of the most
important things
that
managed to push
the reformation story into the world
because the gutenberg press is the one
that printed the protestant literature
it's the one that printed the scriptures
and uh was the
social media outlet of the time
absolutely and it it's a marvelous
instrument
and they demonstrated how it works how
the how the press works now it's
not the absolute original but it's as
close as you can get that they have
there and they're very
very particular
as to how it is used and also the
lettering
is very interesting because the letters
are chosen so that you can print columns
so
as you know bibles are printed in
columns because you get you get more
words in it's
it's more effective
now today
you sit with a computer
and you push a button justify and all
is justified with the right spaces
now with the gutenberg press
that had to be all done with typesetting
the letters in the columns where they
were going to be used
and then
the
the ink was spread over them
and they had to be printed in in
different relays if there was color then
something was done this way etc etc
and the letters the sizes vary of the
letters depending on how they fit into
the column so it's really quite an art
and while we were there
we had
we had a
permit to film and they were
demonstrating it to us
they told us that very few people had
actually been given the opportunity to
print a page on that gutenberg press
and they told us that the ones that had
been there that had done this were queen
elizabeth
george w bush
and then the museum staff
and
eventually
they said
okay i can print one
so that was quite something so
that put me into a very
small little group of individuals one of
them a queen one of them a president
and i was able to print that particular
page now it's in latin
and it has red and it has black on it
and
so it's a very special
very special
piece of
paper and it's framed and it's over
there and it comes directly from the
gutenberg press printed with my own hand
it's in latin
and i'm still trying to figure out
exactly where
and what it comes from i will get hold
of a latin expert and then
we can discuss the merits of what's on
that page but now that you're
part of those
elite of the queen and the president
maybe i should ask the queen or you can
ask the pope because they both know him
very well
[Laughter]
so
yeah that's
a wonderful experience and something to
treasure i don't know whether the pope
would be
elated
about something that came from the
gutenberg press
it set them back a couple of hundred
years
well i was also just thinking that
the healing of the wound you mentioned
it might not be such a positive thing
yeah correct but and
on the other hand it is positive if you
look at the closeness of the second
coming then well
prophecy has to be fulfilled and it's
one of the signs
that prophecy is fulfilling
the children will return
and the children are returning
so
that tells us that
probation must be just about
ready to close that's it so let's get on
to
another question
that people ask
and the question is regarding mark 1
verse 15
and
asks does the kingdom of god hear in
mark 1 15 refer to christ's kingdom that
is coming in our time
when jesus started his ministry
he basically announced that the kingdom
had come
now why had the kingdom come it was
referring to him it was referring to
himself and he was of course the king of
kings and lord of lords
you know that satan had rested the
kingdom
from adam and eve yes god had given it
had given dominion to adam and eve
satan stole it from them
he used them and they became his
servants
but the rightful owner originally was
christ who created it all
so in the wilderness of temptation
satan was overcome
he was vanquished he was a vanquished
foe
but he wasn't eliminated and this is
what people
don't understand
the fact that satan was vanquished and
the fact that he was not eliminated
seems to
be in contradiction
now why did god not eliminate him
because there was still a time of
probation
and a time of choice
for humanity
the six thousand years hadn't been
fulfilled
and so satan was allowed to continue
with his activities but he is no longer
the representative of this earth no
jesus i saw satan fall like lightning
from heaven
his place was taken by jesus christ
so the victory was gained
in
that
temptation in the wilderness
but the price for sin
was paid at the cross
so the price was paid but the victory
was already gained
so
since christ started his ministry the
kingdom of god has come near to humanity
and this is what it refers to
saying the time is fulfilled what time
is fulfilled
prophetic time prophetic time and the
only one that we have is the prophetic
time in the book of daniel
regarding the 70 weeks which says
from the issuing of the decree to
restore and rebuild jerusalem
unto messiah and then comes the time
prophecy which is
which finds its fulfillment in 27 a.d
so from then onwards the kingdom of god
was being preached directly
by god
to humanity
and then secondly onto this is
the parables in mark 4 and matthew how
are these parables like the kingdom of
heaven or of god
all right let's read them
i think please
if we go to mark chapter 4 verse 30 and
to 32 he said and he said where unto
shall we liken the kingdom of god
or with what comparison shall we compare
it
it is like a grain of mustard seed when
it is sown into the earth is less than
all the seeds that be in the earth but
when it is sown it groweth up and
becometh greater than all herbs
and shooteth out great branches so that
the fowls of the air may lodge under the
shadow of it
so the kingdom of god
does not come by observation
and it's interesting that when he
likened the kingdom of god to something
there was nothing in the earthly
kingdoms that he could liken it to yeah
it's interesting right nothing because
the kingdom of god is the antithesis of
everything that we have done here
no wonder we're so miserable with the
kingdoms of this earth right yeah and so
and that's so
sad that we want to restore try and
restore the kingdoms on earth i cannot
wait for them to disappear
in any case so what did he like in it
too this kingdom of god
he likened it to
a seed a tiny seed
planted
in the heart
it will grow
imperceptibly
and eventually before you know it
the trees will be huge and the birds
will be lodging in the trees
in other words it is the kingdom that
grows imperceptibly
amongst humanity
and will never ever be uprooted
but the others
according to the prophecy in the book of
daniel
will be destroyed
because the stone that is cut out
without human hands will strike the
statue at its feet and the entire statue
is pulverized and the wind comes and
takes it away and it will be no more all
earthly kingdoms will be as though they
never were not even a vestige of them
will remain
if we take another parable in matthew 13
verse 24 to 30 another parable putting
forth unto them saying the kingdom of
heaven is likened unto a man which
soweth good seed in his field
but while man slept his enemy came and
sowed tares amongst the wheat and went
his way and when the blade was sprung up
and brought forth fruit
then appeared the tares also
so the servants of the household came
and said unto him sir
it's not thou sow good seed in thy field
and whence then has it tears
he said unto them an enemy has done this
the servant said unto him wilt thou then
that we go and gather them up but he
said nay
lest while you gather up the tears you
root up also the wheat with them let the
both grow together until the harvest
and in the time of harvest i will send
the reapers
gather you together first the tears and
bind them in bundles
to burn them but gather the wheat into
my barn
so martin the kingdom of god has been
sown
the good seed has been sown by christ
himself
you know it's interesting
the bible says they will be taught by
god
god himself came down to teach humanity
and that's amazing and set everything
straight so
it's so wonderful everything that might
have been misinterpreted before
he came and just
put it straight and final so there you
have this beautiful message
explaining the entire kingdom of god
and for your and my benefit it's
recorded in those good books that are on
our table over here
and anybody can study them
but then there's an enemy you know who's
the enemy obviously it's the devil
and he came and sowed the tares
now the tear is
very similar to the original wheat
but it is
poisonous
and if you uproot it you will uproot the
good
seed as well because you won't be able
to tell the difference until it is ripe
until the fruit is ripe
so humanity looks at the kingdom of god
and they see
tares
yes
and tares unfortunately
seem to predominate
and so they think that the kingdom of
god is not very successful
but the kingdom of god
is in fact successful because very often
the very tears that exist
strengthen
those
that belong to the
wheat
because often god allows apostasy to
come into our ranks
so that people will make informed
decisions
that's it and then you go to your bible
and you say now
this and that and this that we are
hearing now
or that we are being told what to do is
that in harmony with what the word says
and so let both both grow together
until the harvest and then the reapers
will be sent now who are the reapers the
angels
because it's again
nothing that we can do correct so he
says go and he sends forth the angels
and they first
gather together
the days the tares
to be burnt
and then the bible says
they will gather his elect from the four
corners of the earth
and they will meet the lord in the sky
they will take them so that they can be
with him forever and then the kingdom
will be established so what happens to
the tares
it's gone they're destroyed yes
so they lie in state for a thousand
years
and after the judgment has taken place
in heaven
then christ will return
a third time
the holy city will come down
a great plane will open up
and
the dead
that had transgressed against god's will
will be raised
corruptable
they will try to attack the city
and fire will come down out of heaven
and consume them
but before they are consumed
every knee will
bow
so the kingdom of heaven is here
even though it seems to be overgrown
and you know it's like the stars
they're not always visible when there is
light
but when it is dark then the stars
become visible
so the darker this world becomes
the brighter the lights will shine
let us pray to god
that we belong to the lights
yes and not to the darkness
thank you very much for that
let's go on to another another question
okay so in one kings chapter 13 where a
young prophet is sent to deliver a
message and come back without eating or
drinking anything
from that place but then gets deceived
by another prophet and ends up dead
it seems unjust that he had to die
considering that the deceiving prophet
was older than him hence he had to obey
and he was a prophet claiming to have
received messages from god
can you please clarify how we should
understand this issue
martin this is one of those
complicated yet interesting stories with
a very very important lesson for our
time
and
one would consider if one looks at it at
face value that god was being quite
harsh
because
this young prophet had come and done
exactly what he was supposed to do but
he was not to eat anything
after all he was delivering
a message to an extremely apostate
israel
and he was to return without taking
anything from anyone that was the
implicit instruction
from god yes
and then while he was doing this and
fulfilling all
the necessary criteria here comes this
other prophet
and tells him
well you don't have to do that anymore
god said
you don't have to you can come and you
can come and eat and drink with me etc
etc
and
he listens to this prophet
and returns
and as a consequence he loses his life
now how important is that message
for us
in our time
it's at most importance because i can
think of a few examples already all
right now
if if you have very explicit
instructions from god
very explicit
and somebody comes to you and says
it is not so
you do not have to do it this way god
told me that it's perfectly fine to do
it another way
and because this prophet is older
you decide to follow that prophet
with without consulting god yourself
and verifying that that is what god
really said you are putting your trust
in a man
who claims to be a prophet of god now
let's let's take a very practical
example
the bible says
remember the sabbath day to keep it holy
that's it six days shall you labor and
do all your work
but the seventh day is the sabbath of
the lord your god
right then it tells you what you are not
allowed to do and then he says why
because i
am the creator of heaven and earth and i
have commanded you to do that
and then an old prophet comes along
who wears a nice wide robe a prophet is
also someone who preaches right
and he says
god actually changed the day
and you no longer have to do that
and let me give you a good reason
the resurrection took place on the first
day of the of the week
therefore you must follow me come and
eat and drink with me because god has
changed his mind
and you say
well that that sounds reasonable you
sound like you know a reasonable prophet
so
and you're older than me therefore i'm
going to listen to you is god going to
hold you accountable one day yes
he's going to hold you accountable it's
not his fault that you choose not to go
his way okay so how imperative is it
that god
demonstrates particularly when he gave
very specific instructions to his
prophet
how important is it
that you
absolutely adhere to
what has been said like we've seen it's
the
between life and death and the wages of
sin is death death so if anybody comes
along and says to you
god didn't mean what he said or god has
changed his mind or god does no longer
require this of you and this is the
favorite terminology
of the world today
god no longer requires this of you let's
take another example clean and unclean
in the bible
100 the same all right
now clean and unclean did noah have have
clean and unclean laws yes he had to
take clean animals and unclean animals
into the ark he knew very well which
ones were clean because there were seven
pairs as opposed to one pair of the
unclean exactly he knew very well
okay
and then the lethetical law did that
tell you what was clean and what was
unclean yes yes right
peter
when he had the vision didn't he say
i've never eaten anything unclean in my
life before
100 and he also didn't after that and he
didn't after that nowhere does it say
that he went and ate unclean meat no
because it died god told me i must not
call any man impure or unclean
so
now
another one another prophet comes along
and says god no longer requires this
because jesus declared all foods clean
yes and then that same guy go and sort
makes that that portion is implemented
in some bibles
yes in all the modern bibles which are
based on those
waste paper basket manuscripts
and then they tell you god no longer
requires it of you
aren't they doing the same here
100 and there's also
if you can pull it through to what's
coming
when satan will present himself as an
angel of light yes also declaring that
the law of god does not stand anymore
because he makes
he's god now what about situations like
we've had
very recently in our world
where people then say god is not going
to be able to help you with this that or
the other
we need to depend on science
so let's take god out of the equation or
what if they say god is not going to
resolve this conflict between nations we
need another mediator who is a earthly
mediator he will be able to deal with
this that and the other
now if god said something trust in the
lord your god
and lean not on thine own understanding
in all thy ways acknowledge him
and he shall direct thy
paths
this is an incredibly
important lesson
as to how
meticulously
we must follow what god has said exactly
and it's for your own benefit because
now some people will turn and say okay
but now he's a vengeful god
this is for your own benefit because
if you don't trust in the lord he can't
help you yes just this week
i got another
question
because
there are certain people that are
bringing out bible manuscripts that
contain
more books 88 books now
instead of the number that you have in
the present bibles
because you know all of that information
has disappeared and it has been changed
and it's not trustworthy and you must
now follow this so for six 000 years
god has given a
non-trustworthy bible
to humanity
and all of a sudden these geniuses have
managed to discover what they consider
their truth
so i wrote back to that person i said if
god is not able to preserve his word
then he is not worth serving that's true
and if for six thousand years
he was not able to give the correct
manuscripts to his people then for 6 000
years he cannot expect them to obey
so
that's just the way it is
it is written what did jesus do when he
was confronted with the devil he started
off with the words it is written it is
written it is written and those very
words that are written are in this book
absolutely and this is the received text
and i believe that this is the word of
god
and
what it says
that is what god requires no matter what
prophet comes and no matter how old he
is and no matter how white his robe is
that he wears
if it doesn't say that in that book
then you cannot listen to that prophet
that's true maybe if i can just add one
more thing here the same goes to the
spirit
if some people say but the spirit told
me
and it's not in harmony with that you've
got the same problem so many ways in
harmony with what the word says you just
read a very interesting book yes the
chant by darkness book of rajan manau
yes and look how those demons just twist
the word here and twist the word there
and all of a sudden
what god said no longer applies and
their favorite one of course is you
cannot die yeah you cannot die that's
the basis of all spiritism the wages of
sin is death the day you eat of it you
will surely
die
so
the two contradictories this just proves
that god means what he says god means
what he says it's absolutely essential
that this is recorded in the bible as
harsh as it sounds
but it is a serious lesson for us amen
let's go on to another question several
places in the new testament it looks as
if the antichrist is a single person as
opposed to a system
can you please explain
well if you look at the whole issue of
the antichrist
and you put the antichrist into
a prophetic
picture
then you will understand that it cannot
be an individual
because the time spans
are over thousands of years that's
correct and if you take the book of
daniel you take the little horn power
it rules for
1260 years
and
that is a very very long time
uh paul
describes
what will happen that the roman system
must first be
the roman pagan system must first be
removed and then the antichrist will be
able to come
and then he will have certain attributes
and then it mentions them in
thessalonians you know that he will sit
in the temple of god pretending that he
is god
etc and he gives all the attributes now
in any phase within this entire period
is also represented by an individual yes
so it can become
very confusing
so if you go to 1 john 2 18 where it
says little children it is the last time
and as you have heard that antichrist
shall come
maybe we're still future yeah
it was still future even now are there
many antichrists whereby we know that it
is the last time
so in other words the spirit of
antichrist
was already working
and if you go into the history of it
simon magus for example
who became the sorcerer to nero
he was the one who wanted to buy
the holy spirit he was practicing what
we call simony
in other words
using money to obtain this blessing
now this simon magus
became the so-called
petra
the rock the rock yes so simon the rock
so who was the real founder of the
antichrist system was it simon magus or
was it simon peter
it has to be simon magus it has to be
simon magus
and the system that arose is a system of
of pretending to have the cloak of
christianity
but underneath you are using sorcery
so
many antichrists
over a long long period one system
that is antichrist
what's the word antichrist mean
it means
in the place of christ
the word anti can mean against
and it can mean in the place of
now in most cases in scripture it means
in the place of
so he sets himself up as god
he's taking the place of god
1 john 2 verse 22 who is a liar
but he that denieth that jesus is the
christ he is antichrist that denies the
father and the son
so if someone says that jesus christ
is not the messiah
then he is antichrist
that's obvious but
you cannot take one
of these these definitions in isolation
they all have to get work together so if
we take chapter 4 verse 3 it says and
every spirit that confesseth not that
jesus christ is come in the flesh
is not of god
and this is that spirit of antichrist
whereof ye have heard
that it should come and even now already
is it in the world
all right now that gets a little bit
closer to home
and every spirit that confesses not that
jesus christ is come in the flesh now
people will say but you know the
religious world and the catholic world
does acknowledge that jesus came into
this world
the question is did he come
in the flesh
did he
come down to meet us where we were
did he take the form of humanity
in its completeness that is the question
catholicism teaches he didn't come all
the way down
he didn't come all the way down
therefore he needs
a
mediation
between himself
and humanity
and that bridge
that has to be crossed this gap that
christ left by not coming all the way
down
is bridged by the priesthood
that's why catholicism has a priesthood
now a priest
is
an individual
that sacrifices
so in the old testament they were
priests
but they served as types
of a higher priest yes they weren't the
bridge they just represented the higher
priesthood
now in catholicism
the officiating
individual becomes a priest because he
takes part in a
sacrifice he sacrifices on the altar and
they claim that the sacrifice of the
mass is the exact same sacrifice as that
of the cross
so they need a priesthood and the
priesthood is in this mediatorial
relationship
and all the saints and mary and all of
them fit into that category so these
priests
actually
become like the creator correct because
they create god from a morsel of bread
they're very proud of that
the bible says he was tempted
altogether such as we are
and the bible says
that because of this
we are able to approach the throne of
god
now according to their system no you can
only approach the god through the
mediation of the priest
and so they deny that jesus christ
came in the flesh in the sense that
he and i
can now communicate directly
and
this is a very important aspect that
many people miss so that actually
qualifies them and in them being
antichrist in
every single aspect 100
so if we continue it says and every
spirit that confesses not that jesus is
come in the flesh is not of god
so this notion that you need a mediator
between christ and humanity
and that the priesthood has been
appointed for that when there is no
mention of it whatsoever in the
scripture
tells us that the system cannot be from
god
and this is that spirit of antichrist
why because it places itself in the
mediatorial role
then it is the spirit of antichrist
whereof you have heard that it should
come and even now already is it in the
world
in other words that spirit was
manifesting itself
and denying the very
basics
of the plan of salvation
in other words catholicism has totally
eliminated the plan of salvation by
placing itself
in the place of jesus christ
for many deceivers second john 1 7
are entered into the world to confess
not that jesus christ is come in the
flesh this is a deceiver and an
antichrist
now if you take some of the other world
religions
what does islam teach about jesus christ
that he was just a prophet
but it also teaches that he never died
yes that he never died it only appeared
as if he died now if jesus didn't die
for me then i'm still in my
sins so in other words it must be part
of the system
and people don't really like that idea
but
you know the devil does nothing in half
measures
nothing if we take this compared to what
we've just read in one kings chapter 13
again
there's no other name
so that means there's no ala the
religion correct now
catholicism denies the atonement
quite clearly
jesuit teaching denies the atonement
therefore the the jesuit order
is the very pinnacle of the antichrist
system
islam denies the atonement
so in other words it's part and parcel
of the same religious antithesis to what
the bible teaches and people will have
to make a choice
you either have to believe what the word
of god says or you have to believe that
other prophet that tells you you don't
have to
which forms part of the antichrist
correct
let's look at john 5 43
i am come in my father's name and you
receive me not if another shall come in
his own name
you will receive him
that's exactly what we just spoke about
what jesus has said
and what he has made available to us and
what is written down so that we can
understand it
is denied by these other prophets
and they come in their own name and say
this is the way you must be saved
through our system and through our
sacraments and through our works-based
system
and through
this merit system
this treasury of merit that has been
given to the pope
to hand out
grace as he deems fit
excuse me
grace is being handed out by jesus
christ and no usurper is going to rob me
of that grace as long as i cling to what
the word of god has to say
so yes there are many antichrists
and there are many systems that belong
to it but there is only one
antichrist system that has the goal
to officially
call itself
the representative of jesus christ true
thank you very much
let's go to another question
if the high priest went into the most
holy once a year in the earthly
sanctuary that jesus entered in 1844
only once and then again once a year
thereafter into the most holy in the
heavenly sanctuary
martin
people have this rigid notion
about the movements
of god
they have this fixed notion of a throne
that stands in a throne room
and god sits on his throne
he's pinned down yes
but if you take the vision of ezekiel
then the throne was mobile
it got wheels and there were wheels
within wheels and the hand was under the
wheels
and it turned
and
it was it was a system that was
that was absolutely
harmonious
and yet it looked confusing
so god's throne is not a fixed throne it
is a mobile throne
so what happened in 1844
is that the ministry of christ
moved from
the first chamber ministry to the second
chamber
ministry
that doesn't mean he was nailed down
and it also doesn't mean that the
service that was done in the
holy
is now
done
jesus still
is the bread of life
is still the light of the light he's
still interce he's still the intercessor
now
what was the difference between the
first chamber and the second chamber
the first chamber as we all know
contained the candlestick the altar of
incent and the altar of showbread
and
the altar of showbread actually is also
a throne yes
it is also a throne yes
in the most holy you had the ark of the
covenant covenant and then you had the
mercy seat over it
which shielded you from the condemnation
of the law
so what happened in 1844 martin was that
we moved into the anti-typical day of
atonement
which stands for judgment now judgment
needs a standard you cannot have
judgment without a standard of judgment
if there was no law
there would be no transgression
so if there is transgression that means
there must be a law
correct now that law is the law of ten
commandments now judgment cannot
commence
if the law is not the basis now where
was the law in the most holy the law had
been transgressed the law condemned us
to death
therefore we need a mercy seat to shield
us from that condemnation who is the
mercy seed jesus christ now was jesus
not shielding you from the condemnation
before the day of atonement no he was
doing it constantly the whole time all
the time
so you cannot pin
this down
the earthly is a
enactment an example of the plan of
salvation
it's not a rigid interpretation of where
you have to stand
if that were the case the poor priest
would never be able to do anything other
than what he did but he also went home
and he ate and he drank and he was
married and he had children and he had a
family and he did all of those things
but he officiated
that's it
for a year in the holy
and officiated the high priest for a day
in the most holy
so
the ministry of christ moved from the
holy to the most holy in 1844 and the
law
had to become prominent yes so the
judgment commenced
since 1844 continuously correct
so
if i can just put it maybe like this
jesus is not standing 24 hours a day in
the most totally probably no
definitely not
but the ministry that he is engaged with
that's it is most holy
ministry
anti-typical day of atonement ministry
and very soon when that ministry comes
to an end the decree will go out let him
who is holy be holy still
etc etc
thank you let's carry on with another
question
at the end of time regarding matthew 24
37 to 39 and luke 17 verse 26 to 30
it sounds as if life will be carrying on
as usual when jesus returns i'm having
trouble wrapping my mind around this
how can life be carrying on as usual
when plagues and calamities are
happening as well
as the death decree that will be enacted
in the end
i know the main idea is to be
spiritually prepared and i know that you
guys do not know each detail to every
question
i'm just hoping for some insight into
how these verses fit into the end time
events and prophecy
all right
let's have a look at some of these
verses
matthew 24 37-39
so these are the verses that he actually
mentioned in the question
or she
but as the days of noah were
so shall also the coming of the son of
man be for as in the days that were
before the flood they were eating and
drinking marrying and giving into
marriage until that day
that noah entered into the ark and knew
not until the flood came and took them
all away so shall also the coming of the
son of man be
what this verse is telling us
in the essence or what it is describing
is a certain form of normality
now is there anything wrong
with eating and drinking
no if you don't eat and drink you die
all right
marrying and giving into marriage is
there anything wrong with that
no
so why does the bible mention this as
specific things in the days of noah they
were eating and drinking and marrying
and giving into marriage obviously
they were doing this in excess or wrong
or not getting according to god's will
right so they were eating and drinking
in excess
they were gluttonous
and they were
marrying and giving into marriage
whoever so they pleased they changed
partners like garments do we have
similar situations today yes yes and it
seems normal all right now
when we had a pandemic last year
or when there was a tsunami
yes there was a calamity major
calamities were people still eating and
drinking yes and were they still
marrying in excess and divorcing in
excess
and
all the other permutations as to who and
what you are marrying
and this excess exists today so this is
the context in which we must see it
so if we rephrased it we would say as it
was in the days of noah
so shall it be at the coming of the son
of man
there will be excessive excesses in
eating and drinking
there will be gluttony
there will be starvation on the one hand
and extreme luxury on the other hand
and there will be all kinds of
abnormalities when it comes to human
relations and you see this actually adds
on to what we've been saying
everything that's happening
and will come
it's not going to be
oh here it is now
it's just gonna form part of this whole
catastrophe that's going on yes and if
we if we read the same story in luke
chapter 17
from verse 26 and as it was in the days
of noah so shall it be in the days of
the son of man
they did eat and they drank they married
wives they were given in marriage until
the day that noah entered into the ark
and the flood came and destroyed them
all
so there will be a total destruction
because of their excesses but then he
gives a little bit more detail in this
way likewise also as it was in the days
of lot
they did eat and they drank they bought
and they sold they planted they built it
but the same day that lot went out of
sodom it ran fire and brimstone from
heaven and destroyed them all
so destruction is going to be total why
would he mention lot
because there's another
portion of apostasy that comes in there
there's an aspect there in other words
they were so blasphemous
and so licensures
that they were even willing to violate
angels
how disgusting can you become and they
were so
entrenched in earthly possessions yes
it sounds like uh
some of the
the laws and legislations that we are
getting in the world today
and uh you know i'm i'm almost scared
that whatever they are saying will soon
become compulsory
then i will have to move to the poles
and become a penguin
even thus shall it be in the days when
the son of man is revealed so this has
to do with excess
that is why it appears normal
but it's not
now if we
put in another portion here
this time of noah
is that before
or while
the last plagues are falling
well until the day that noah entered
into the ark
the day that noah entered into the ark
is the close of probation so typically
that is when the place will start
falling correct so this time is actually
showing to right now yes we are living
in this time just before noah enters
into the ark now what is the antitypical
ark
the church the church which one
those that keep to the commandments of
god and have the faith of jesus
and how to the testimony of jesus
that is
what the ark comprises of because that's
the invitation
so martin
i hope we have dealt with this question
yes
i also think that
if you put it in this context
that people will start realizing we're
already living in these times so it
won't be that oh all of a sudden you're
going to stop everything that you do
because you're seeing this yes
thank you
what does the bible say about cremation
martyrs did not have a choice but for a
funeral what if one does
well martin this is a very
personal issue a very sensitive issue
and i've received
a couple of letters in this regard of
late
and
also some studies that people had worked
out
as to what does the bible say about
cremation the bible doesn't really speak
about cremation
it does mention
that
some people were burnt like saul
he was burnt
and
jonathan
they cremated the bones
now jonathan is he is he lost or saved
he's probably saved yes jonathan
jonathan was a good guy right and he
he died under those circumstances
so if cremation was a problem
like catholicism
originally taught that you should not be
cremated
because
you would not be found when christ came
to resurrect the dead
and
therefore their enemies were burnt
and wycliffe was
dug up and his bones were burnt and
pulverized and
the ashes were thrown into the river
swift
now does that mean that these martyrs
that all burnt will be lost the answer
is obviously no
but the bible does speak about burial a
lot
and
right from the beginning you read about
the burial places that abraham secured
and how meticulous they were
that they were placed in the right
burial chambers
even joseph
asked for his bones to be taken out of
egypt back to correct israel
there are a couple of questions here
is god dependent
on the physical material that you ex
consist of in order to resurrect you no
all right
how often do you change the physical
material that you consist of during your
lifetime i think don't you do it yearly
every
eight months about you are a totally new
person
so in eight months time i'll be looking
at another martin
a little bit older one yes every mineral
and everything will have been replaced
by then and you have a constant turnover
so biologically
who are you
and on what part of it is god dependent
for your resurrection
character
yes he's interested in your character
and he's going to give you a
new body
a totally new body what that looks like
we will find out one day so purely
scientifically
what is the difference between normal
decay
and cremation
scientifically the process is speeded up
right there's a tremendous speeding up
of the process
and
what is the advantage of the one over
the other
well people are emotional
about
bodies and burial places and graves
and you know if you if you have an
identity and you can go and see
that person's grave that you
feel very close to
that gives you some form of comfort
so does that mean that the bible
condemns cremation
no
the answer
is
no because you cannot find it in the
bible
so it is a very personal decision i
think so as to whether you should
allow cremation or not
now in some countries where space is of
the optimum like in japan for example
you rent a grave for a while and then
after i think two years or so you have
to
make room for someone else
because space is just
of a premium
so there are all of these issues now if
i can relate a personal story which is
not always a very nice story
but
my parents were buried they weren't
cremated
and my mother was buried in a in a
family grave
and then her twin sister when she died
was buried in the same grave
and so the grandmother and the family
they were all in the same grave
and then a couple of years ago the city
decided to expand the road system
and so they had to exhume the graves
and they had to remove the bodies
so they
told us about it and we went to the
gravesite and they were busy exhuming
the graves now what they were going to
do is they were going to take the
remnants and put them into new
ossuaries or into new coffins and then
re-bury them in another grave that had
been set aside for this purpose
now
when we got there they were busy now
the graves are only of a particular size
so
those that died earlier were buried
deeper
than the others so some were buried very
deep and some were buried less deep my
mother had died very early so she was
in one of the lower lower portions but
my aunt was in one of the higher
portions
and as the man was busy with his pick
opening up the grave
all of a sudden the skull of my aunt
came up on the tip of the pick
which was
very disconcerting
and
so all of these things
make you think you know what is
what is the purpose of all of this
and then again you have the other
situation
is
that
the burial sites are not what they used
to be i mean it was it was a place of
quiet in the past it was well maintained
and then
neglect came in and eventually vagrants
came in and there were grave robbers
trying to find jewelry
somewhere on the corpse etc etc a lot of
desecration
and then you wonder what is what is the
dignity that is still left in all of
this
so these are choices that people will
have to make but my personal opinion is
that
the one process is just a faster
than
the normal decay
biblically
there is
no verse that speaks against cremation
fact of the matter is
many thousands upon thousands if not
millions of god saints
were cremated
not by choice
but by
the actions of their enemies
and therefore god is concerned with
character
but if your emotional attachment is such
that you cannot deal with it then by all
means
use
burial
thank you very much
let's go to a final question yes
this is a question that we get quite
often
how does one deal with demonic activity
well i get that question
almost on a daily basis
and it seems as if
the problem is on the increase
now having come from an occult
background martin
i've had personal experience with
demonic activity
i myself have been
involved in it
i have
partaken in seances
been strangled by demons i've had very
personal
encounters with the demonic world
and
the deliverance which
i received
was not because of
an exorcism
even though it appeared so for a while
because while i was still unaware of the
truths of the bible
i had the catholic church come and do an
exorcism in my
house and that exorcism was very
dramatic
because as the priest was performing the
exorcism
he was
apparently attacked by the demons and
thrown around the room
and eventually
once the activity had been performed
and he left
there was no more ant demonic activity
in my home
and so of course i attributed this to
the exorcism to the ritual
now the ritual entailed
making holy water
with salt
and a cross within the salt
and then placing this water around the
house and sprinkling it etc
and then saying a mass
within the house
and it was a very interesting experience
because
those who know my testimony
will know that all the animals came
running and it was a very very strange
situation
but when i discovered the truth
and started tugging on the chain
then all that demonic activity returned
with a vengeance
so was it really a successful exorcism
no
not at all no it was a deception
in other words the devil pretended to
withdraw himself so that i would be
entrapped in a greater lie than i was
before before i was an atheist
now i would have been trapped in a
religious system that is contrary to the
scriptures
and so i learned a very valuable lesson
there
so what actually
stopped the demonic activity then prayer
prayer stopped the demonic activity
that doesn't mean that the harassment
stopped that's an important point please
elaborate on that all right let's talk a
little bit about that
today there is this notion
that you call an exorcist or a priest or
a pastor
and he commands those demons to
leave the place
now if you go into the bible you will
see that there were others also that
commanded demons
to depart
and the demons said to them well jesus i
know
you
paul i know
but who are you
and then they beat them up right
so the magic word
is not a magic
potion there are people that go around
commanding demons to leave in the name
of jesus christ
and it becomes like a power religion
because the power is then centered on
yourself
the power never lies within yourself the
only one who can confront the demon
is jesus christ himself
this one will not leave except by prayer
and fasting
in other words when it comes to fasting
does that now mean i stop eating for a
week and the demons will shudder and and
leave immediately
then you have to go to use a zion is
this the kind of fast that i require to
afflict your souls for a day or two or
whatever
no
get your life in harmony with christ and
prayer
in other words pray and bring your life
in harmony with christ
that is the answer to demonic activity
so
when people ask me how to deal with
their demonic activity
the first thing i ask them is is your
life in order
is there any influence that you
bring into your life like media yes that
might
be opening this door what is opening the
door are you obeying what god has said
you ask god to help you with this that
and the other but he's already told you
what his requirements are
the holy spirit is given to them that oh
obey him that's very clear in the
scriptures
meticulous obedience to the precepts of
christ
is an absolute essential component
in the same way i cannot pray
for someone's healing
as long as he refuses to adhere to
health principles that's it if he
doesn't want to give up smoking and he
doesn't want to give up drinking and
putting into his body what is harmful
for him
then all the prayer in the world won't
help him if he is stubborn exactly
and the same with demonic activity so
get your life in order ask yourself the
question what is it in my life that is a
hindrance
and set that right and then prayer
in other words asking god to do
something for you which you are not
capable of doing for yourself
amen
and then
faith
once you have known down and said that
prayer
then you must appropriate it
you must accept by faith that the prayer
has been answered
let me give you an example
martin luther
was
plagued by the devil
when he was
translating the bible
at one point he was so angry he took his
ink pot and threw it at the devil but of
course he missed because he couldn't see
him
it was a futile exercise
and he was so harassed
that he could hardly work yes he was so
harassed people can relate to this
the harassment can be ongoing and it can
be very severe
but then he realized all of a sudden
that he was alive
that means that the demon that really
wanted him dead
was not able to kill him
so who prevented the demon from killing
him
jesus
jesus prevented him from killing him
and so he came to the conclusion
that the devil was making a lot of noise
and so he said
devil
your aim is to kill me but christ is not
permitting it
and therefore
i will not allow this harassment to
affect me anymore
you can do what you have to do and what
you think that you can do whatever god
permits is fine by me but as for me i'm
done and i'm tired and i'm going to go
to sleep
and for the first time he had a good
night's sleep and he continued with his
work
now many times people are harassed by
demons
follow the procedure make right your
life
pray lord i do not belong to that entity
i belong to you
i have been bought with the price
command this demon please
to leave me
alone
and then you thank the lord for his
blessings
and you accept by faith that your prayer
has been heard
and you say to yourself my god is not
death
he's not baal
that he should not be able to hear
neither is he on a long journey
he is not
deaf he can hear me
and therefore i accept that my prayer
has been heard and then if the plates
fly against the wall so be it that's it
it is this is exactly what happened to
me too at one stage yeah the plates were
flying through the room and crashing
against the wall
and then there was
deathly silence
the same happened with roger minnow yes
we've mentioned earlier i can encourage
anybody
get that book charmed by darkness read
it because he had the same similar
situation that you said he eventually
dealt with it yes through prayer and you
know there's a statement in the spirit
of prophecy there will never come a time
when the hell is shadow of satan is not
cast thought your path he's not going to
let you alone he's going to harass you
he's going to make it as difficult as
possible
then you ask yourself a question
why lord why me
wrong question
why not why should it have happened to
jesus why should it have happened to all
his disciples why should it have
happened to all the masters and you be
spared of all the harassment
but you have a promise god will not
allow him to tempt you beyond what you
can endure
and this is where simple faith comes in
so in order to get rid of demonic
activity do what is right
leave it in god's hands pray to him to
resolve it and then by faith accept that
he has done so get on with your life
and the devil will flee from you amen
will you pray for us yes
heavenly father
we are living in very troubleless times
and we need to have faith
help us to grow our faith
so that no matter what happens to us
and on what no matter what happens
around us
we will not be shaken
help us to cling to the rock in jesus
name amen amen
[Music]
you